hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 4 2019 what's going on
how are you Oh am i in a good mood sorry
for the late podcast I'm still wrapping
up acting on General Hospital and what
I'll tell you what a nice day off I had
yesterday what you guys do yesterday uh
did you sit around did you watch the
bowl of super Patriots went again
unbelievable I absolutely loved the game
even if we lost that game I would have
loved it as far as just the defensive
battle it was a punters clinic a punters
duel but a lot of people didn't like the
game like it's boring you know they like
those 52:48 games I don't like those
games I love the Rams front four I love
their defense their coach the whole team
I just think they're they're gonna get
there soon and I cannot believe that the
Patriots won again man I don't know what
people go aren't you getting sick of it
no I'm not it's [ __ ] awesome I love
it I hope they win it again next year
the same way you would if you were my
position I don't give a [ __ ] and you
know I mean I'm so happy as a sports fan
and satisfied as a sports fan I was
talking to a Canadiens fan go well they
were like oh no gonna break up all the
Stanley Cups that we've won and I'm like
I don't think I god bless you I'm glad
you got him I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
maybe the Lakers are the only ones that
bug me just because they count one
championship that isn't a championship
other than I so hate that Bill Simmons
let me know about that because there was
another stupid thing for me to fixate on
but anyways
Gronk with a big catch Edelman the MVP
our defense played unbelievable
obviously it helped that Todd Gurley was
hurt and then the game kind of got put
on golf shoulders and we were able to I
don't know I don't know if disrupted
enough but uh we definitely got lucky I
thought they were officiating overall
was good
couple ticky-tack calls on both sides
couple of [ __ ] calls on both couple of
non calls
un-fuckin'-believable
but i don't know what else to say other
than i I hope this keeps happening
sorry other than that if my team isn't
in it then I always root for you know I
don't know Kansas City or the Browns if
somebody hasn't want it and [ __ ]
forever or ever so that's it I had a
Super Bowl party yesterday I got on the
grill just made some burgers and dogs we
smoked a cigar and I did what I always
do is we tape the Super Bowl we shut off
our phones and we let it we let the game
be 90 minutes old before we went in and
we did it perfectly this year because we
fast forwarded through every single
commercial we only watched two
commercials because I had to go out and
go flip a dog and I was running the
remote so they actually watched two
commercials blew right through the
halftime show didn't see a second of
that and what's great is is the drama of
the game stays with you instead of
having all these [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] other people and analysts and
all of this [ __ ] I mean the game takes
like what like four hours to play or
something I mean it's already long
enough at three I don't need another
extra hour but fortunately all the
things that I missed all the commercials
in the halftime show I actually have an
expert on the Super Bowl halftime show
she's not listening because she's
looking at her phone Nia I saw the game
you saw the how was the I was the
halftime show it was a mess it was I
mean what about maroon 5 guy where you
go out he's taking control of me yeah I
have tattoos and yeah what about he took
his shirt off young ladies did not go
like oh my god no no no we did not
uh at least I didn't you know what I
used to really I liked maroon 5 when
they first came out it was like oh this
is some like nice fun good harmony is
nicely sustained yes I would no no not
about dancing but it was just kind of
like oh this is like some Pleasant like
you know harmless like white boy kind of
poppy music get all racial about it tell
you what it is so I think that's fine
flavor when the well with a decade
that's the problem is that you know he
started to feel himself a little bit and
Adam Levine Levine is incredibly
talented young man and I back in and I
wish him all the best but I yeah it's
just I wasn't really like my cup of tea
Travis guy was on there which is like
okay fine
I like that song I guess Big Boi was
there so that was cool but it's like if
you're not with Andre 3000 like do we
really care Jesus yeah I'm going in you
go I did hear that there is a dungeon
family tour that's gonna be going on
starting in the spring so that's very
exciting if you're from Atlanta you know
what I'm talking about is the most
[ __ ] up podcast I've ever done kiss
you I want could you had no idea what I
was talking about now I don't know I
don't want any of those people are I
haven't maroon 5 is do you know who
Travis Scott is he's like on he's a
rapper okay I was born you know who bit
okay
do you know who big boy is from Outkast
yes right so he performed I'm sorry miss
Ogden
Jackson Miss Jackson sorry
roses really smell like boo boo boo
what's the one song where the white
girls always clap two times
hey yeah right yeah yeah there's a point
where they clap two times at all no
white girls are excited when they know
how to do any show like three times
whatever they do so you know I mean it
was pretty it was pretty boring to me
was pretty uneventful I mean I want you
to watch the [ __ ] game the game was a
boy's kind of I was in and out you know
hey what about them doing that city of
Boston New England all that we've won 12
[ __ ] championships since 2001 I mean
that's like getting a facial
12 days out of what kind of thing
no it's not seeing I'm listening our
four little teams we have one in our
history we've won 38 championships in
New York the state of New York cuz is
where most of my friends are and they're
always breaking my balls is they have
they have ten professional teams if you
include the Islanders the Sabres and the
the bills and all of those ten teams
combined they have like I think 41 we're
only three behind them it's good that
it's ridiculous and you know well I
could say thank God we all saw this cell
cuz I say thank God they have the
Yankees but thank God we have the
Celtics to get our number up there but I
know this so when does basketball season
start next year they take a year off
every other year they have basketball
season now no it has to do with the
polar vortex it's been happening since
no they don't take every other year off
I'm not that [ __ ] clueless about
sports like no not me honestly I was
saying that the season started in
October that's not next year I know it's
happening right now the see what is
didn't you say when is basketball yeah
yeah yeah well it's happening now trol
in college a Laker game no me why I
[ __ ] hate the Lakers oh Jesus I hate
the Lakers I just can't stand their fans
can we just go and sit in a section with
like some old-school Laker fans from the
80s and make they could talk to me about
what it was like to go to the LA forum
and and what it was like back then when
they actually had knowledgeable
basketball fans as opposed to that
Staples Center where it's just one of
the worst arenas where it's like you
have the whole down-stairs section for
all the halves and then they have like a
3-story of luxury boxes and then they
stick all the regular people way at the
top of that building well what if they
were playing I don't know what if
they're playing the Celtics could we go
to it then I
are you serious you're not gonna take me
like I like going to the game yeah
enjoying the game I go out here and it's
just like you know listening to all of
that [ __ ] and then if you wear any
Celtic stuff just the whole [ __ ] game
all I'm gonna be thinking about is
punching the person behind me they just
some cons out here it's weird because I
saw a Red Sox [ __ ] the Yankee Stadium
and they break my balls but after a
while we would just be laughs and
drinking together and we would have a
pronounced out here you get stabbed in
the parking lot yeah they're just
[ __ ] it's just not you sure when ice
cube ice cube did the [ __ ] voiceover
on like a 30 for 30 for the Raiders
mm-hmm he sounded like he was like
trying to be like he was in [ __ ] I
don't know what and some Stephen said he
was in NWA I mean you know he's not
gonna like you know do like in 1980 so
like that's not he's gonna be like yeah
that wasn't like that it was like
terrible a terrible I ski but he say he
was like upset like I was listeners like
this guy is literally angry talking
about going to a [ __ ] game and they
like they want championships like I
don't get it out here where it goes to
that level of like it's like hey I'm
into this team and then all of a sudden
you're like in the middle of like a
blood and [ __ ] fight it's just like what
we can't set that aside just go to a
[ __ ] game we're going to a game you
say that like Boston fans aren't like so
I don't know I think you don't die in a
Boston game you don't Philly they'll do
[ __ ] to you you don't die you [ __ ]
people die out here it's [ __ ] I think
all sports fans are crazy but I know
somebody got shot at a pre-season Raider
49er game baby what are we doing here
yeah that's know that's terrible yeah
guy takes his [ __ ] kids to the Dodger
game
he's wearing a giant's Jersey he gets
brain damage these guys stomp them down
in front of his kid I know but I was
terrible yeah so what you're saying is
we're not gonna go to a Laker game just
based on the fact that if the Lakers
even if they play the Celtics um no I
you know it's like if you really want to
go to that yeah I I like
I think they're fun I mean I go to
clipper games I'm more fun but I'll go
to a Laker game like a game it's just
like it's like going is like a [ __ ]
nightclub yeah I'm there with their
[ __ ] Botox and [ __ ] it's just the
Wits weird yeah but if you sit up top
it's cool I like the Laker fans I'm not
[ __ ] on all Laker fans I'm not
[ __ ] on all gonna get a lot of
tweets after this baby not [ __ ] on a
lot of LA fans I'm not I'm just saying
that they're you know you know the fact
that they had they had to bring body
bags to a parking lot it's just a
[ __ ] IIIi don't know it's terrible no
the older I get the more it's funny how
loud I am and how much I scream and yell
but I have this this weird thing now
like I don't like watching horror movies
I know a little scaredy-cat with the
horror movie
no it's not that it's the peril you
don't build us alike movies where people
are in peril because he's annoying
he feels helpless and he feels like like
that heightens like anxiety and the
feeling like he doesn't like that like
he can't like he doesn't feel
comfortable I will I go to a movie to a
narrow gate that I walk around to
feeling that arrow
yeah and panic and what the [ __ ] and how
old am i and should I see my parents
more and what the [ __ ] am i doing and
did I wait too long to be a dad and
Alicia and I'm gonna add a [ __ ]
horror movie anxiety to that but it's
not real it's a movie do I buy India
yeah I buy it okay Blair Witch scared
the [ __ ] out of me the ring scared all
these people do do do scare me it scared
the [ __ ] you know these are legitimately
scary though oh my god Asian [ __ ]
[ __ ] that yeah then no joke did you
ever watch the babadook no you didn't
want it I watched as it was a kid it all
was so good though it was so good [ __ ]
that movie I'm saying that with all due
respect all due respect [ __ ] you movie
no what's a nice you know what to an
all-star game one time I went to an
all-star game at the Staples Center it
was the year after Boston and wanted so
Doc Rivers was coaching so he was the
coach of the east and the end of the
West I remember it was a [ __ ]
all-star game it was just down to having
a good time so at one point he put the
big three out there Garnett
[ __ ] Paul Pierce and Reggie Lewis or
whatever right it was it was I got
Reggie Lewis what I was [ __ ] name is
doesn't seem right uh was it Louis no
Reggie Lewis was a guy who died yeah I
was no I Allen Ray Allen okay all right
Ray Allen yeah so they put the game so
they put yeah the three of them out
there this is an all-star game and then
they're you know I'm when they they had
their minutes or whatever did their
little alley-oops and [ __ ] right
they going back to the bench and I just
hear this guy just go I'm thinking who
the [ __ ] does that and an all-star game
I looked over and it was ice cube ice
cube strikes again like what are we
doing here I don't like this that's the
thing about it like you know you know
what's killing me is I got some New York
fans friends of mine that the last time
the Red Sox when we had Bobby Valentine
we had that lead in September and we
choked choked it away I mean I I had
[ __ ] friends of mine I not heard from
them and [ __ ] as far as sports go
eight years and they came out of the
woodwork good you look good both you
[ __ ] Joker's and all that [ __ ] this
is what I love since then we've won two
World Series and two Super Bowls I have
not [ __ ] heard from them so I'm not
saying this not [ __ ] on the East Coast
but I just never feel like I'm gonna
walk away with like some sort of
physical harm hmm I don't know
I liked you know I don't get to be home
a lot so I like stay at home you got a
flat-screen TV at this point I don't
need some [ __ ] mouth-breathing [ __ ]
who plays fantasy football [ __ ]
sitting behind me you know having that
[ __ ] you know that [ __ ] vibe were
there just looking for that mean I
almost gonna fight and [ __ ] San Diego
charger game years ago years ago a
literally the security came up and I was
rooting for the Chargers I just wore a
Patriots had this was like I don't we'd
only went three at that point it was a
long time ago they were playing the
Colts and of course I was rooting for
the you know his baton it was a I was
rooting for [ __ ] the Chargers and I
and I wore that hand I didn't think it I
didn't understand
how much they hated us down there but I
wasn't being an [ __ ] and we weren't
[ __ ] plain the pages weren't even
[ __ ] playing and I still almost got
into a fight it was [ __ ] insane
so I trying to square off with the guy
that [ __ ] [ __ ] right then he's got a
whole other row of people that [ __ ]
back in him I remember in the end when
we finally squared off he took his
[ __ ] Shaun Merryman Jersey off and
[ __ ] threw it down somehow no and how
you know is really going down yeah cuz
he was it was all like he was all like
yeah he was doing the big you know
cotton puff well not lunging at you and
then someone would grab him then all of
a sudden he's the [ __ ] Tasmanian
devil right all I know is somehow you
know the pushing and shoving and they
were behind us so they were gonna be
punching down it would have been bad
unfortunately security came up and uh
India I'm telling you like I was in I
was in like my late 30s for yeah late
30s that's a I'm not looking to get into
a [ __ ] fight I was excited like oh
this is another football stadium I went
to I was excited that I've been to a
Padre and a San Diego a charger game I
could check off both those stadiums on
my quest to go to all the stadiums right
and I loved Joe Robbie Stadium I loved
Air Coryell and Dan Fouts and all of
those [ __ ] guys that's what I that's
where my head was at and next thing you
know I got this [ __ ] [ __ ] so
somehow security comes up and literally
had to escort like make us wait until
they left because it was the end of the
game but but somehow my buddy swiped
that kids [ __ ] Jersey it was like an
official I don't know how he grabbed it
but then we had to walk out to the car
with literally with like yeah head on a
[ __ ] swivel and I think that's where
some where your hat off as you're
walking out and it's not in sight no
more violence my you know I think I
might have I think I might have yeah I
mean I'm not trying I'm not trying to
fight ten one of my [ __ ] Lex Luthor
over here I was trying to think of a
[ __ ] action hero ya know yeah any one
of those even that [ __ ] [ __ ] took
his jersey off he probably could have
beat me I'm old what I'm just saying
they're beating people like I've been
working out with my trainer again sorry
um are we done with your story yeah
okay great so I've been I've been
working out with my trainer and we've
been doing a lot of like the boxing and
stuff and he's been like I you know I've
been working out with him for years but
I still sometimes have like a weak wrist
when I punch him when we were running
like our drills and stuff and doing
heavy like my wrist will bend and stuff
so he was trying to show me like how you
know when you're punching somebody you
know you're meant to really kind of get
them like on the chin with your first
two knuckles and that's the middle thing
yeah yeah which I did know I kind of
thought yeah I thought it was just sort
of like this flat part of your hand that
you're supposed to like connect with I
didn't realize dud knuckle sandwich
that's what you're meant to like clip
them with so when I was punching him I
just I didn't have my hands in the
gloves I just had them wrapped and he
had his like his bare hands up and he
just had just tapped me and when I was
really like connecting with that [ __ ] it
was like oh that's what it feels like to
punch somebody and then to put like the
weight behind it it's like I don't know
I'm looking forward to using it life
most people they do throw a punch they
actually usually get their ring
knuckle and and the pinky they end up
you because just I also think it's if
your arms about you won't break your
wrist or something like that yeah you're
supposed to keep it because he was
showing me up against a wall like this
like that and he was having me like push
against it with my knuckles and he was
like that's that's what you wanted to be
on there's nothing to like you haven't
since since you know I was a young man
it was just people squaring off nobody
kicks and [ __ ] [ __ ] kids today
there's all this UFC [ __ ] you know and
this is the thing there's no ref to jump
in and break that [ __ ] up yeah
somebody's gonna get you know chokehold
and when you go out you know and these
Adrenaline's going I mean the guy could
give you a brain damage or kill him it's
just [ __ ] it's just a whole other
level of [ __ ] that I don't know I'm just
at some point you become an old man and
I am an old man and I don't mind going
to a baseball game but not out here I
just had you know where it was I think I
had too many bad experience at an Angels
game Dodgers games I always had good
experience because I really liked the
Dodgers LA King games I had because I
liked the Kings and I liked the Rams and
like I actually like the charges - but
is I think it's maybe it's just like
Laker games I don't [ __ ] though hmm I
don't know yeah I mean my whole [ __ ]
job is just getting heckled and getting
yelled at I don't need to [ __ ] go to
a game does that make sense - no sure
yeah we were going somewhere with that
that that watching that horror [ __ ] no I
was saying how you don't like peril that
that it gives you anxiety when people
are in like very tense like are they
gonna make it out alive
I don't like documentaries about real
violent [ __ ] that happened either like
everything do you see murder mountain
people kids go up to the mountain and
they get murdered you want to watch that
and it was weird I'm like watch people's
parents crying I don't want yeah it's
weird like I'm on the fence because I
like true true crime stuff like I like
true crime podcast I like documentaries
I've read books on truth I love a serial
killer so I don't know I love a serial
killer honey but but no it's a little
disturbing now because especially
because Netflix has like the Ted Bundy
tapes and then they have another Ted
Bundy movie coming out and it's sort of
like I don't know I haven't watched any
of it because I'm just like I don't know
am I just supposed to be like so
fascinated by this like horrible man
that goes around like raping and killing
all these women like is that supposed to
be like intriguing to me I don't know I
was just reading something though on
Twitter where they found the same jail
cell and in Texas where Sandra bland
allegedly committed suicide they found
another black man hanging in there and
it's just like really this is the second
time anyway that's kind of off topic
Sandra bland whoo Sandra bland yeah she
was the black woman that was pulled over
for making like an illegal lane change
and the cop went nuts on her and like
went completely overboard and then all
of a sudden she was like hanging in her
jail cell over like a traffic but like
it was just like this whole horrible
horrible story so they just found a
black man was hanging in that same jail
cell where they were like oh I don't
know she took a you know [ __ ] trash
bag from a trash can like a trash can
liner and like hung herself and it's
like I don't know
my point is yeah what is the point I
don't know I went opportunity cuz no I'm
kind of outraged by that but uh no I
because I've been going back and forth
about whether I'm gonna watch this Ted
Bundy thing because I do like crime
stuff but I don't know yeah folks had
Bundy and [ __ ] like watching a whole
thing about his true when they went to
go kill him or whatever then he started
[ __ ] all through the bodies are you
know this all that [ __ ] like all of
those children of people that he took
away yeah [ __ ] that guy yeah like I
don't about him and people being like he
was so handsome and done it's like are
you kidding me
this was like a depraved horrible cycle
you had that I don't like when they
[ __ ] show like these [ __ ] mass
shooters they show the person and it's
like [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that person yeah
like I honestly think that they
shouldn't even report it the other
people need to know what the people
trying to catch that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and the next of kin other than that
you keep sensationalizing that [ __ ] and
it's it's it's like I I literally think
like that's you know like how how I
watch stand-up comedy and it made me
want to do comedy I think when psychos
watch mass shooters like that's like
them watching evening at The Improv
being like oh I want to do that copycats
and stuff yeah your career aspiration
career day for psychos I don't know well
this podcast to turn a sort of a dark
turn didn't have good what's we talked
about slight infest you talk about
Valentine's Day Oh Valentine's Day yeah
well so we never go out on Valentine's
no wait but I have to talk about this
really quickly because on Twitter
someone tweeted me and was like hey show
us the bag the toothpaste bag that bill
was talking about and I just wrote back
dare I cuz I don't even know if I want
to put it out there I'll go you got it
you got in my head now and you know you
know something I actually started
looking at the bag and I'm starting to
see it I get it you're you're more
advanced than
I am is when it comes to like light and
not letting me finish my sentences
you're more advanced when it comes to
that [ __ ] you can go to a museum and
actually have an experience where I just
sit there going oh my god I got to be
[ __ ] outing you like where's the bench
that I can sit on but it's not a piece
of art no but you I told you like sort
of the significance of why I wanted a
piece from that collection right like I
text you that did you get that did you
get that text for me do you check your
text messages for me do you read them no
it was part of the douchey [ __ ]
collection no big fan of his alone his
art to do that none of this is true bag
this is Virgil a blos first collection
for Louis Vuitton menswear okay he is
the first black creative director for
Louis Vuitton so this is kind of a
historical thing this is a piece he does
like the menswear this isn't like he
does the women's clothes just as the
menswear so these bags for a guy it was
created for the menswear collection but
anyone can carry it yes Bell okay oh so
it's like a gender-neutral bag I guess
it's about that he did like socially
progressive art pieces I was out of this
now I'm gonna say that when is the
hashtag something something my what do
you call me to hashtag what myself also
yeah anyway but I don't know you got in
my head now so I don't know but so we
got to figure out what we're doing
because we never go out on Valentine's
Day but your schedule this year is kind
of like screwy so you know we might have
to go out and Valentine's Day all right
sorry Charlie I'll take you up for a
hotdog how you take me to pink hotdog
and you know what I wouldn't mind that I
was [ __ ] there's always seven thousand
I remember was just a food truck you
just walk up and get it we went down
there that one time it's in Chinatown
there's like 7,000 [ __ ] people it was
like yeah yeah I was like sleeping up
for tickets concert
it's in the 70s I'm like it's a [ __ ]
chicken sandwich did you bring me one of
those chicken sandwiches one time no
you've always told me about it but you
never brought me one because it used to
be when you got your hair cut
r.i.p bill's hair but anyway have you
thought of something like romantic to do
for me or yeah my take out to dinner
that's it you have somebody come over
and sing oh I have an idea
see if I can pull it off that person
that I am he didn't tell me there are no
noise will do nyquil shots as we look
each other in the aisles yeah say good
my baby I gotta read some [ __ ]
advertising here I could do that you
know you always call yourself freckles
right yeah but I where are your freckles
on your face I don't even see them
anymore do you have them you have them
on your arms but like I think they all
combined into one sad Friday
Oh freckles a giant birthmark all right
oh look who's oh my god they're back I
thought they were done with me Sherri's
berries oh my god for Valentine's Day
dumped me they did I came back to their
old flame
Valentine's Day is right around the
corner talk about what plans for
Valentine's Day this year what you would
do if you weren't procrastinating well I
don't like the insinuation that I'm
procrastinating you sons of [ __ ] have
you planned anything huh no all right
then
sherry is very good about I told you who
to call to set some up no you didn't
share a personal Valentine's Day story
oh the classic one when we went out for
the sushi and you were staring at that
celebrity we got that big fight oh my
god did you punch me in the face no wait
a minute you're telling it all wrong
yeah that's what happened no wrong boy
you're telling it all wrong
you didn't have that personal trainer
that you punch me with you picking up no
yeah you were a little tiger back then
I'm still a tiger baby
do you remember I have the ultimatum
which was why if you throw something at
me again during a fight I'm breaking up
with you
mm-hm and you know what you stopped
abusing me yeah I was definitely a lot
more volatile when I was younger and my
younger days we met when I was 25 Bell
so come on yeah I was you know a college
graduate you were an adult I paid rent I
had a job now I was a fully warm well
past I mean listen it was also 15 years
ago bill we've been together for 15
years can you believe that it's been
great all right what would you do okay
share a personal Valentine's Day I just
did
what are your must give what is it
muscle what is a must give you must give
me what
Jewellery [ __ ] off this whole [ __ ]
but I gotta buy you something that's why
I love sherry berries is your chocolate
strawberries all right so you're met
with the excitement enthusiasm wasn't
met okay what are you wait a second
where'd it go
now they're definitely not coming back
to you now what yeah well what do you
what do you to look good what do you do
that was missing though the words
missing it says what do you two look
good on Valentine's Day
no dipped in milk dark or white you're
definitely dipped in milk hey milky no
no no you be white chocolate no yeah I
thought it's lighter okay dipped in milk
dark or white chocolaty goodness for any
discerning palate she'll fall in love
with every bite
top with decadent toppings chocolate
chips heart and glitter sparkles always
fresh always tasty always worth the wait
perfect companion to a candlelit light
dinner a bouquet of flowers or a night
out on the town
if somebody knows gonna stuffed up here
I'm sick gettin emotional reading this
copy arrives fresh with a hundred
percent cherries berries guarantee I
want to know who the [ __ ] is dipping
those in chocolate right now
that's sad bastard ships wish somebody
loved me
[Laughter]
ships anywhere nationally give sweet
something's to your long-distance love
Oh God whatever boyfriend your other
boyfriend put him in a race for dreams
at the price of your dreams because they
left me so you know this is gonna be a
little rocky as we get back together
starting at just $19.99 plus shipping
and handling plus order now and make
this Valentine's really special by
getting double the berries for just $10
more go to berries calm dude you the
[ __ ] berries kid BER RI es calm click
on the microphone editor the code my
code Barbie you are our check out that's
BER RI es do T Co and click on the
microphone and enter code per order
today
okay I'm back sorry I tell you right now
bill burr if I don't get a box of
Sheree's berries for Valentine's Day I
would be very very disappointed oh here
we go
[Laughter]
with millions of top-rated sellers
offering the exact same products on
Amazon finding the best deal
feels like looking for an invisible
needle in the world's biggest haystack
but thanks to the free browser extension
I always get the best price on Amazon
without lifting a finger
honey automatically goes to work
whenever I shop on Amazon you love it me
it's funny it compares the prices of
every seller that carries the item I
want honey
even factors Oh
Hut even factors in shipping sales tax
and Amazon Prime status to make sure I'm
getting the lowest total price it shows
me the best deal every time even if
Amazon doesn't it's like having my very
own personal shopping assistant honestly
it is so easy to use it feels like
cheating but it's not it's just a smart
automated deals finder that gets me
millions of shoppers the best price on
Amazon every single time what did you
buy with honey on Amazon I bought some
honey more than 10 million people are
using honey to save money honey has over
100,000 five-star reviews on Google
Chrome store Time magazine says it's
basically free money so the next time
you're shopping on Amazon don't wonder
whether you found the best deal just add
and get the best price automatically add
honey for free and join honey calm /
birth that's join honey calm / / alright
Jesus Christ how many more of these
[ __ ] things policy genius at Nia
policy genius life insurance is one of
those topics that everyone knows a
little about but do you understand it
well enough to feel comfortable buying
it whether you're an insurance expert or
a newbie policy genius created a website
that makes it easy for you to compare
quotes get advice and get covered policy
genius is the easy waiting of life
insurance in minutes you could compare
can you realize there's people out there
need a handicapping one you're gonna die
and they're trying to [ __ ] you over does
it I believe isn't it great that policy
genius exists Nia to try to figure out
what your bladders gonna give out yeah
all right sorry hit up limit goes here
right from okay policy Jesus is these
ours positive use is the easy way to get
life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at the price you
can afford from there just apply online
and the
visors at policy genius will handle all
the red tape they'll even negotiate your
rate with the insurance company no extra
fees no Commission sales agents just
helpful advice and personalized service
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy whether you're shopping
for disability insurance to protect your
income homeowners insurance or auto
insurance they can help you get covered
fast so no matter how much or how little
you know about life insurance you can
find the right policy in minutes at
policy genius com policy genius the
easiest way to compare and buy life
insurance I need to learn cuz you're
over there staring at your phone look
near its 1-800 ProFlowers alright bye
now most of us have started racking our
brains about what Valentine's Day gift
is truly gonna make her Day special why
isn't there anything about the [ __ ]
guy this is such a stupid [ __ ]
holiday it's an it's taken a [ __ ] day
huh isn't it's taking a [ __ ] day no
that's smoke that's allegedly in March
it's not official oh there's no pressure
hmm
I mean but before this me too [ __ ]
there's no way it could be like honey
what the [ __ ] a [ __ ] 1-800 profile or
1-800 ProFlowers bite these are the best
of the best flowers yeah mmm most of
them their their dream died as a flower
at the college level by now most of us
have started racking our brains about
what Valentine's Day gift is truly gonna
make her Day special yeah like that's
gonna make her happy she'll find
something with 1-800 flowers shot Bob
well you guys are inherently not happy
people you know what it is we're
inherently I don't we you're too smart
for your own [ __ ] good that doesn't
make any sense that's not a robe when
people say that what does that mean
you're too smart for your own good that
mean that I'm smarter than you yeah and
you're like perplexed by it you don't
know what to do with it so sometime
somehow you're gonna take my
intelligence and use as an insult
against me it's not gonna work you're
too smart to be happy that doesn't make
any sense you never heard of fat dumb
and happy what no
nobody happy no these were these
old-time you say can you just run out
and moments wins could be into you ever
heard of fat dumb and happy no bill
because it's not a thing that people say
that dumb and happy return let me to
look it up
not really why don't you read the rest
of your advertisement
why are you dictating to me in my own
podcast my podcast now you like showing
off don't you I do you do well I'm a
curator all right here we go with 1-800
flowers calm it's really not that
complicated
roses what color roses near Rose you'd
get red violets are blue there's purple
you know [ __ ] many many different colors
but the one yes all right I'm sorry no I
guess they are what's your favorite kind
of rose I should know this by now
I would bomb on the newlywed game fifty
degrees under this what's your favorite
rose I don't know roses aren't really
like my favorite flower though what do
you like sunflower reg you [ __ ] grill
I like um big as my head I like I like
orchids
I like black dahlias 100 flowers are a
no-brainer right I like orchids I feel
like I'm stuck in an elevator right now
when you want
I like gardenias 1-800 flowers has
amazing deals on vibrant and romantic
Valentine's rose bouquets arrangements
and more starting at just $29.99 there
are so many unbelievable deals 1-800
flowers but you have to hurry just get
this done get her the [ __ ]
chocolate-covered strawberries get her
some flowers that'll shut her up for the
weekend roses from one and flowers are
picked and shipped overnight to ensure
freshness in her amazement amazement
gorgeous Valentine's bouquets and
arrangements starting at $29.99 is an
amazing deal but it won't last long
bouquets prices will be going up soon so
take advantage today pick your delivery
date and let 1-800 flowers handle the
rest when it comes to Valentine's I
don't settle for anything less than my
rose authority 1-800 flowers calm did I
just join a religion to order
Valentine's bouquets arrangements
and more starting at $29.99 go to 100
1-800 flowers calm click on the radio
icon and enter BER bu our our order
today and save a 1-800 flowers comm code
ber actually the greatest Valentine's
Day gift that you guys give men is that
you don't have one for us yeah because
then we would have to you know get
dressed up and go out and go do some
more dumb [ __ ] that we don't want to do
you know if you could just let us sit on
a couch and eat something while watching
a game and actually feeling like that
affects our lives in some positive or
negative way if you could just let us do
that that's enough of a Val I'm speaking
for a little bit right now
yeah wow you guys really are very simple
creatures okay well I am NOT so you know
I know you well enough dear yeah to know
that there's something else really
[ __ ] bugging you I don't know if it's
something I'm doing hey or if it's just
something don't know why you're going on
with you yeah oh that is me what do you
mean what the [ __ ] did I do now nothing
I know foolish [ __ ] I'm gonna tip you
over their [ __ ] chair [ __ ] get
this stupid [ __ ] look I know that
look alright bill great emails last week
you announced the new California dates
right after mentioning that you were
filming a special soon so a bunch of
people thought maybe you were filming at
one of them and we're emailing asking
which one can you clear that up for them
Thanks yeah I'm not filming a special
right on the 15th 16th or 17th but I am
going to give my darndest of an effort
those are the shows to get ready to do a
special plowing ahead I'm obsessed with
Santa Barbara that's where all rich
white people move to be next neared
Oprah
who wants some hash isn't she a
Montecito
I don't know stalker face uh Rams name's
name okay the Rams aren't I I was only
wondering why the the Los Angeles Rams
serve originally from Cleveland Ohio
like how the [ __ ] did they get ramps and
the Rams are named the Rams because the
Cleveland owner the original owner of
the Cleveland Rams went to Fordham
University and their name was the ramps
and I guess he liked it coincidentally I
am from Cleveland and I'm a freshman
affordable Vince Lombardi also went here
all right
that's well then now this is like now
I'm to Ford him so how did it Ford him
is that Fordham the college in New York
I don't [ __ ] know all right
NFL titles dear Billy [ __ ] balls on
your podcast this past Monday your
audience had to listen to you [ __ ] once
again about how football championships
prior to the afl-nfl merger aren't
counted do you realize that you can't
complain about this almost every [ __ ]
week
no I don't enough already I listen to
the second half of the podcast last
Thursday which was from 2011 and you
were whining about it then as well well
it's playoff time you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you've been bitching about this for at
least the last past eight years so what
I've also been talking about the
population problem get the [ __ ] over it
you sound like the creepy uncle who at
family gatherings tells the same stories
over and over again please stick a
tampon in pull your panties out of the
crack your ass straighten up your skirt
and just let it go now what the [ __ ] is
this person somebody who doesn't have a
[ __ ] answer for what I'm saying who
the [ __ ] is this person throwing out
these that kind of language and that
kind of insults how dare you
Nancy Internet that's like a joke don't
write into my husband I'll pull your
tampon player panties out go [ __ ]
yourself you know bad you're making me
look good you couldn't handle the
[ __ ] period every month you piece of
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up with your lame ass
like sexist [ __ ] remarks
Jesus Nia what [ __ ] hashtags were you
read today he's just trying to be funny
and not succeeding well you know what I
like is he that's so lame
it's like so [ __ ] unoriginal
much comb your hair get it deep
conditioning put your rollers in your
hair and put a bonnet on like I think
anybody goes that deep but well they
should maybe they should like try
something new try some find out some
other stereotypical [ __ ] about women
that you can throw in there huh what
happened to you today I don't know that
let her bug me and it's lame ass why did
you take your tampon out all right
currency hey Bill remember a few years
ago I loved it I loved that that guy
wrote all of that [ __ ] because he could
not answer it I I will I have an open
forum since - the guy wrote dear Billy
[ __ ] balls and I want you to explain to
me the thing about it is is no one can
answer to me why they don't count them
it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
whatsoever that's the usual reaction
currency hey Bill remember a few years
ago when there was a bit of attention on
how [ __ ] up the banks are no that's
still a problem this country is bankrupt
which is why it was which is so [ __ ]
up that Trump was trying to get us out
of Syria which were to save this money
and even Democrats were voting against
that because they all get paid by the
corporation's their nia all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] who want to raise our
[ __ ] taxes they're who all make 150
200 grand a year they're all
multimillionaires how did they do that
Nia huh hello all right there were
documentaries made about the housing
crash in 2008 and that movie with
Christian Bale the Big Short was a hit
so much so much of the middle-class
wealth was transferred to huge banks in
that time it's really the worst thing
that happened to this country all
violence aside it's the only issue that
if exposed properly would actually unite
the country no one likes being taken for
a sucker and that's all the banks have
done to this country of course the news
won't pound away at the issue the way it
needs to be done because they're heavily
influenced by the powers that be what do
you
think why do you think there hasn't been
a grassroots movement about this because
I think just generally speaking people
can't get along with each other and even
if you're starting a movement then
somebody doesn't like your version of
the movement and then there ends up
being like fighting amongst yourselves
you know what I mean we did that happen
to Malcolm X Nia yeah I'm just trying to
wake you up there yeah there becomes
like infighting or whatever I just
really said that to me to get me a pay
attention yeah
but it was also also point about I was
trying to make their oh you say like why
didn't why don't regulate all mobilized
and on the same [ __ ] page about these
banks how come there hasn't been this
grassroots movement what it doesn't
exist somewhere well I think the powers
that be always turned it into a it
becomes a Democrat first Republican
issue and then if anytime you know
people with you know that
Wall Street thing everybody was trying
to say that they're a bunch of hippies
and [ __ ] privileged white kids and it
just gets labeled and then then you just
you start fighting about the labels and
then the issue just goes away it just
[ __ ] goes away and I was just saying
how I don't know just human beings in
general we just don't get along with
each other set and people choose
self-preservation like all these [ __ ]
politician pieces of [ __ ] on both sides
that have allowed like a handful of
corporations to literally bankrupt this
[ __ ] country in neverending [ __ ]
Wars and then they put the pressure on
all of us support the troops and support
this and support that and so you got to
stand there and [ __ ] salute
everything while not questioning it as
they basically vacuum up your kids
future
you know the supports troops what troops
they [ __ ] bringing back here they
treat them like [ __ ] I know I can't even
I can't even like [ __ ] get going on
that subject it's such a it's the
biggest crock of [ __ ] ever
alright stalking stalkers are more but
the way they treat [ __ ] veterans
it's unbelievable it's [ __ ] it what
do they just wheel him out at football
games so they can sell you know whatever
the [ __ ] they're trying to sell all
right there you go buddy now good luck
with the rest of your life stuck is a
Mormon nobody this is Ben hey Billy
burnt tits I don't know what the [ __ ]
that means I'm feeling kind of stuck
stuck is a Mormon hey Billy burnt tits
Vic Mia can you get off of your goddamn
phone make me feel like half my audience
doesn't I'm feeling kind of stuck I'm 19
years old
and I've grown up Mormon my whole life
recently I've sort of stopped believing
in the church but here's the problem I
go to BYU I didn't plan on going there
but due to the fact it's super cheap and
it's a good school I decided on going
here anyways parenthesis I'm a dumbass
no you're not bi is a good school I
still don't believe it any of this stuff
I'm ready to religion in general the
problem is then I don't want the whole
rest of my life to be determined by the
Mormon upbringing I would rather not get
married to some Mormon chick or anything
and I'd wait I would rather not get
married to some more Mormon chick or
anything and I don't want all of my
friends to be Mormon after I graduate
college I don't want to leave the church
and lose all my friends in dating
prospects unfortunately I can't really
afford to transfer anywhere else and my
whole family is all in on the church so
I would be majorly disappointing my
whole family by leaving any advice from
you or the lovely Nia would be much
appreciated thanks and as always go [ __ ]
yourself you know one day I was at the
airport and I saw this white woman
wearing yoga pants and on the side of it
it said do you boo and I remembered
[Music]
[Laughter]
you got a do I swear to God I did see
those yoga pants really I was so bad it
said oh no ha no I took a picture of
them it said do you boo do something
like something something but take no
[ __ ] you know people like how like who
have to like say like what they are on
their clothes like warrior I mean just
like did I just fact that someone would
breed with that do you know what I would
[ __ ] do if you came up with pants
that said do you boo yeah I would rip
them off of you I would do that in
public
oh so you're telling him that he should
do what he want I mean I think you
should finish your education work save
money and I think you should get the
[ __ ] out of there and go expand your
horizons like you want to and you can
always come back you can always change
your mind but if you have this impulse
that you have a bigger destiny then
what's the church and this sort of like
small group of people different destiny
not rather than a bigger destiny because
that's gonna people put people at odds
just yep you have a different agenda if
you have a bigger destiny you feel like
than just that small area that you're in
I think that you should follow those
instincts and I'm sure every other
Mormon kid your age at Brigham Young
that's what it is
we revisit it know what is that three
bigger I'm sure that they're all
thinking the same thing you are
what so it's a right deal about what we
have to live what happens in natural
life according to the Mormon self yeah I
don't I don't [ __ ] so why would you say
the afterlife is not what they're known
for
one of them's have to be right aren't
they known for like I don't know
polygamy and like you don't know [ __ ]
about 20 I mean listen I watched every
season a big love on HBO okay I think
I'm pretty I think I'm pretty
knowledgeable about Mormonism I got I
think Chloe Sevigny was very very very
convinced
yeah this is like he's listening he's
eating the same food every [ __ ] day
it's driving him nuts
yeah he's eating like you know [ __ ]
mayonnaise sandwiches Oh wheel out the
podium hi dad how did you why did you
pick that card again I just talked your
way out of this one
no I just meant like like a bland like
non exciting [ __ ] you bought you lying
your ass on Mormon Utah it doesn't get
any whiter than that that is mayonnaise
white I mean and you said it and you
have to live with it man I need to know
can this person follow up is it true
that Mormon people don't like black
people can I can we just I just need to
know why would they when you call it a
man easy puffy just said don't you get
the mayonnaise off your face near before
you got all their wives looking at you
looking like goddamn Little House on the
Prairie
air down to their feet jebediah Ezekiel
Isaiah Mary Anthony
like them and all their [ __ ] 20
children I mean sorry
that's not nice I said not they're not
like those people in Pennsylvania the
adirondack people whatever they [ __ ]
the Amish yes yeah okay I mean no they
use electricity yeah did Hamish don't
yeah they just say look like you know
they're like Hitler was gonna have a
summer camp yo whatever it is I think
they drive our own cars and [ __ ] yeah
the Mormons do yeah yeah they're totally
modern yeah I'm talking about no I'm
just being cheeky because I know I'm
talking about the the fundamentalist
which are not you know they're not they
don't do that anymore I just crazy
college being a long [ __ ] time ago and
Mormon school and I had to work totally
[ __ ] clean some college out there yeah
yeah they were all virgins but they were
like they were saying the ones who did
bad
uh-huh was they would bag to girlfriend
in the ass and she was she's still
considered a virgin that doesn't make it
any sense at all well I mean no sense
because you can't get pregnant if they
like pop you in the ass well I think
it's our time it is still intact right
Oh God
all right I guess it's sort of a fender
bender of [ __ ] anyway this young man
seems like he wants to explore life
outside of this Mormon church life and I
encouraged him to do so like I said get
your education work okay make money save
your money and like go to New York and
have your mind blown or la by the way
Michael so hates oh I love Michael he's
he's so [ __ ] so in [ __ ] Boston sports
but we have won so many championships
he's now been reduced to like making fun
of our skyline
he's like Boston has all the
championships you can't front on that
but you know the just little [ __ ] is
one-horse town
yeah okay what else you gonna make fun
of the Big Dig next how far away from
sports are we gonna get here sorry so do
what would you say about a woman mm-hmm
she never been had vaginal sex mm-hmm
but she's been bagged in the ass you've
had sex
it was anal sex but you've had sex well
if I could equate this to baseball it's
like she skipped the base right and then
you're out okay so yeah don't get credit
ya know you're not a virgin if you've
got [ __ ] in the ass I'm sorry that's
just not how it works what base is that
in what world are you a virgin if you
had anal sex and like but you're like
how are you still aware that doesn't
make any sense
first base is kissing second base is you
feel about okay
kids don't use that
four bases and stays is you yeah had you
[ __ ] him its anal is that you back in
the dugout that was a long way to go
long way to go be me well with your
[ __ ] heckling could you come along
for the ride you're supposed to be a cub
was supposed to be a comedy team here oh
sorry
alright goodnight Gracie all right
ruined my brother's year hey Billy
badonkadonk love all your work super
excited to see you perform in New York
this February oh yeah at the Patrice
O'Neal benefit ok so here's where I
[ __ ] up by the way do we have any
[ __ ] nyquil something that I could
just [ __ ] suck down here sure go to
sleep mm-hmm what is going on with you
nothing it's the way you said it like
sure just maybe like you're not pouring
it you [ __ ] put something in oh I
don't know why you mad at me but you are
alright I'm not mad at you
god you're such a [ __ ] egomaniac it's
like every mood I have has to do
something with you I did I not ask a
half hour ago is this about me or is it
something else I don't remember you what
are you Ronald Reagan
they don't recall you dogs that well
[ __ ] rewind it for you
alright you know what [ __ ] you mood I
don't give a [ __ ] then alright how about
that so that's not nice that's [ __ ]
cold I mean you don't have like the
plague cold it's like like you're dying
you're a little stuffy because I'm so
sweet you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna order a [ __ ] giant meal for you
and for me and then we excuse myself
[Laughter]
alright so here's where I [ __ ] up this
past New Year's my family went to
Burlington Vermont Oh Burlington Coat
Factory
mmm-hmm I have a twin brother then we
had our own hotel room for the night
is this where you start bagging a chick
and he excused yourself and then he
comes it is that is that this game
though I mean let's find out don't twins
do that oh what base is that the switch
the old switcheroo the old faceoff with
your dick no matter how much you do we
still laugh still laugh alright okay I
have a twin brother we had our own hotel
room for the night we're both in college
you get the pictures so New Year's night
we go out to a bar and the place is
[ __ ] packed ladies everywhere and
cute ones too I see this girl with some
fat titties busting out of the top of
her sweater and my animal instinct kicks
in he's just being honest Nia he's just
like you know I'll shut up like you guys
don't look at some Johnny wad comes
walking in you're like oh I wouldn't
mind swinging from that trap easy
they're basically okay some animal
instincts kick in basically we had an
absolutely amazing time but got
separated assuming we meet back at the
hotel room after a long night I stumbled
back to our hotel alone wait a minute
this is not going this direction I admit
I had a wee bit too much to drink when I
open the door my twin brother was
shirtless with not one but two girls in
his room now I'll admit I was a little
surprised but good for him right I
thought he didn't say that she was
[ __ ] his brother he's twin brother
the girl with the titties not realizing
that it was the other person anyways as
I'm grabbing my stuff to go chill in the
lobby while he plays a doubleheader one
of the girls says your twin is pretty
hot directed towards me immediately I
start thinking what the [ __ ] that I just
walked into I kind of laugh it off and
continue getting my [ __ ] my twin brother
comes over to me and asked for a condom
this is all very weird
give it to him and all my way out he
again she says you're not staying we're
related the way can I just ask a quick
question is it like one of those twin
things were like with your brother
ejaculate it's like you can feel and
creepy twin [ __ ] sounds like a Jim
Carrey movie as soon as I heard this
something in my gut said they are
hookers
or I could have been or I could have
been or it could have been all the booze
I had that night it just didn't feel
right got to go with you got dude anyway
I took a closer look and to me they
looked kind of trashy like Lady Gaga
after one too many bush lights
immediately I say and what I thought was
a low voice bro don't do this they are
hookers oh god I know I know it's [ __ ]
up but I'm in a foreign environment I
don't know what goes on around in
Vermont Oh
sleazy Vermont Oh Vermont has a massive
heroin problem Wow yeah you wouldn't
want to [ __ ] anything without a coat
about there see that yeah you don't know
everything I don't why don't you make
another mayonnaise covet you so much so
unfortunately the girls heard me it got
really bad Oh God did you [ __ ] up his
threesome I said [ __ ] it and left him to
do his business I came back an hour
later and all three of them are gone the
next morning he comes in it tells me I
[ __ ] the whole thing up for him oh
Jesus
oh dude you guys there's no comeback
from this after I left they said [ __ ]
this and left he convinced them to go
back to their place but once they got
back there they just put all their PJs
and went to bed bill I know I was wrong
for messing up a threesome on New Year's
Eve and I feel terrible about it my
brother wouldn't talk to me for days
after it happened
all he would say is you [ __ ] up my
whole year so I was thinking of paying
for to actual clean hookers
what this is your solution he's got to
go to clean hooker org it have them pick
him up from a bar without him knowing so
he can have a threesome business it is
Ryan your brother needs to get over it
and if he could pull two chicks before
he can pull it again and quite frankly
he must not have had that much game to
begin with if he couldn't convince him
to stay so you know he could have been
my all my brother's [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't listen to him here let me eat your
[ __ ] and then boom it would all been
like done but he didn't think fast
enough in the moment he couldn't keep
the thing going because he just got dumb
luck that he had he knows he knows it
was dumb luck
that's why he's mad cuz he knows he
knows he doesn't have the [ __ ]
ability the skills the pimp game
to pull two [ __ ] again so that's why
he's mad but she can't do anything about
clean hookers and have them pick up and
orchestrate this whole [ __ ] thing and
now you gotta pay five grand or whatever
the [ __ ] going rate is would be my
rate if I were a hooker but you know all
that na na na na na he blew it you
didn't help but he couldn't keep the
thing going not your fault I have so
many questions first of all they sound
like they young yes okay he's getting
it's free so there's no way to pay this
back alright he did [ __ ] it up but this
is they do you like if he was a really
good brother he would've been like
yesterday and he could have taken the
other girl and he gotta bangs him in
that bed and then he could have banged
him in the other bed [ __ ] and then
they just switch off that's gross and
then they could just like take turns
with each girl or whatever that's what a
real brother would have had [ __ ] but
he wanted to be disgusted he wanted to
be selfish and like keep them both free
love would you [ __ ] do that with your
sister no we don't get down like that
well what what the [ __ ] with these guys
because who kicks out their brother so
they think of bang to girls that's so
rude
you can't share I don't know what are
you saying I don't even know anyone
yes he [ __ ] up the threesome there is
no comeback don't get hookers yeah don't
get how you there's no such thing as a
clean hooker you gonna get a hook under
our first day she's gonna suck at her
job no pun intended
I wouldn't there be clean hookers though
I feel like if you're a good respond oh
no need why wouldn't there not be a hole
of the ozone layer that's like there
there's how you wish the world was in
the way it is okay [ __ ] what was
right out of the box well I mean if they
get tested and they use protection and
stuff that it could very well be that
they don't have any STDs I mean I don't
know how you would check that but in
what why was your price five red I don't
know I just threw it out there because
I'm thinking of like the high-class
girls you know the ones I have like the
really nice websites know what world
you're in okay that's that's a cool
enough line for you in that situation
eat your [ __ ] just like that I mean I
don't know something something that's
just kind of like I forget about him
it's all about us ladies I think I like
to eat your [ __ ] line better all right
dilemma who would buy them giving us
gold by the way I'm sure it is
okay so so what would you do how how is
he gonna make it up to him he has to own
it
and just be like yeah I did I was drunk
and I [ __ ] it up and they have to
laugh about it and then eventually you
know hopefully his brother will get
another threesome and that'll be over he
won't huh
he won't know he will that's why you so
mad he knows it's not gonna happen is it
he's mad cuz his brother [ __ ] up a
threesome you gonna be writing that
story when they're 50 years old at time
I could have bang those two broads at
the [ __ ] thing and you can laughing
he'll be laughing cuz he's gonna get a
null oh he'll get another one why he's
so [ __ ] negative he already pulled it
off his brother just came into [ __ ] it
up that's all dumb luck I'm telling you
oh no I just have a feeling alright you
go with your gut well I have a guy my
gut feels this guy's you know
hang in there tiger you'll get that
threesome you always wanted I don't get
it alright dilemma
who would you revive from the dead to
talk to for one hour Jesus Christ or
John Bonham oh Jesus Christ without a
doubt just so I could watch him talk to
everyone the world be like I never said
that I didn't do that what Jesus Christ
would definitely be the more fascinating
person to talk to
oh yeah cuz you might be able to unravel
an entire [ __ ] religion he said bottom
your idol even as two as a guest on a
podcast maybe jam with them the most fun
you've you ever had or clear up a couple
of things with the Savior roast him for
walking on water thing et cetera ask him
on the podcast if he Minds year-old
Jesus if he laughs then pious [ __ ] the
world over can never say another world
yeah I would definitely go with Jesus I
would definitely go with Jesus yep no
disrespect to John Bonham but like I
wasn't friends with John Bonham you know
but Jesus whenever I had one pair of
footprints
it was then yeah like tonight I'm gonna
ask him to take this cold from me
usually be in the guest room right with
all those germs yes I really am in like
a weird mood I'm sorry yeah I know it's
a time I apologize everyone for this
crazy I like it I guess I could sure
you're [ __ ] cool with me that's a fake
laugh you're [ __ ] crazy right now
I'm not crazy
hired I'm a little punch-drunk I'm a
little drunk I had that little cocktail
earlier oh you did something loose with
my words make it [ __ ] booze and my
[ __ ] goddamn face aren't you
Oh Billy freckles over here 72 [ __ ]
wonderful days without alcohol look
better you look great
well skin is clear but your skin has
always been clear you've always had good
skin yeah well my head hasn't always
been clear that's how I met you
all right listen god bless you Nia
Thanks thank you for doing the podcast
congratulations to the real people won
the [ __ ] Super Bowl the the New
England Patriots players of the whole
organization it's just it's [ __ ]
unbelievable that the I thought this
this year was a rebuilding year the fact
that they somehow and they you know they
beat the San Diego Chargers they beat
the Kansas City Chiefs and they beat the
Los Angeles Rams there's not a soft team
in any of those so it's one of the best
championships we've won and go Celtics
go Bruins let's keep the train rolling I
want to see what Rappaport makes fun of
us for next dude I went on the Freedom
Trail it's [ __ ] overrated
all right that's it have a great week
and I'll check in on you on Thursday